قررت الكفاح من أجل الديمقراطية وحقوق الإنسان
عندما كنت جالسًا في صف أوهايو ستيت الخاص بي
أشاهد الآلاف من
خيرة الشباب في مصر يخرجون إلى الشوارع
مطالبين بحقوقهم الأساسية في
حرية الخبز والعدالة الاجتماعية
في يناير من عام 2011 ،
وأذكر أنني كنت جالسًا في
تاريخي الأمريكي  تم لصق الفصل
للتو
على جهاز iPhone الخاص بي تحت
الطاولة واشتريت تذكرة طائرة وذهبت وكنت
أحد شخصين على تلك الطائرة
إلى مصر ، تم اعتقالي في
25 أغسطس 2013. تم اعتقالي من
منزل عائلة والدي في ضاحية القاهرة
قضيت 22 شهرًا في السجن
أه أمضيت 16 من تلك الأشهر 489 يومًا
في الإضراب عن الطعام لقد فقدت نصف وزني
تقريبًا أموت
ما يقرب
من اثني عشر مرة في
السجن تعرضت للتعذيب
الجسدي لقد تعرضت للتعذيب النفسي هذا
الشعور الذي حصلت عليه بمجرد  تم
نقلي من الطائرة في عام 2015
بعد أن أمضيت عامين
في سجن مصري هذا
الشعور بالحرية وفجأة
تحصل على حريتك يمكنك أن تفعل
ما تريده  يمكن أن تقول ما
تريد
هذا الشعور لا يقدر بثمن
هذا الشعور
يستحق كل مخاطرة